i am really sorry
to honestly no word of a lie
the hundreds of people that are
messaging me about the property
investors crash course
especially in london because it's sold
out
the london one sold out the manchester
one sold out
the leads won even the swindon one
swindon like
who lives in swindon it sold out
portsmouth
sold out birmingham sold out i'm really
shocked
it's up they sold out within like a week
or two every single crash course that we
have
so i wanted to give you a little free
gift um
anyone that can't make it to the crash
course any all the people that have
messaged
me saying hey samuel can i can you
squeeze in one more place
and i feel like a jerk as well because
people are like oh man i'll just stand
at the back of the room
or can you just squeeze one more and
some of the people that are messaging me
like i know them they're like
friends but the thing is if i said yes
to every person that asked me can you
just squeeze one more place on
then there'd be a few more hundred
people at the programs
and in all honestly honestly i didn't i
didn't even know if people were ready to
come out the house i was thinking
we're doing the online courses we've got
samuel 365
shall we even put another property
investors crash course back on right now
people ready for it
it just sold out so i'm really happy to
those of you that have booked on the
crash courses like i can't wait
i know that the lockdown's kind of being
pushed back again so
it wouldn't have to be social distance
and stuff i'm not really dealing with
that my
operations team dealing with that i'm
just going to turn up and bring fire
i'm going to personally be there if you
booked on quickly and you took action
then massive massive congratulations
it's going to be an incredible
training program and i can't wait to get
to know you i can't wait to meet you
if you didn't book on i've got a free
gift for you again i'll talk about that
in a minute wait till the end of the
video
um but you know what i was just running
a training program this morning at the
lease option boot camp and
i said to the guys napoleon hill said he
said this he said
if you can conceive it and then if you
believe it
then you'll receive it and i thought
what a powerful question i shared that
with the guys this morning
and i realized that the reason most
people haven't got
unlimited amount of wealth the reason
they haven't they aren't millionaires
the reason they aren't buying properties
using strategies like lease option
agreements and using other people's
money is because
they can't even conceive it you know
so some of you guys are like is this
even legit how does this work how do you
structure a no money down deal a rent to
rent is it legal you can't even conceive
it happening
well the first step is to conceive it to
understand it
and then when you understand it then you
have to believe it
then you have to believe that it's
possible for you and then when you
conceive it and you believe it
then you can receive it and it's a great
quote from napoleon hill
and that's what's going to happen at the
crash course you know you've already
conceived it
hopefully you you believe it and that's
what you've booked on and now it's going
to be time to start receiving some deals
and getting some results
so free gift is this on amazon right now
my new book which is called the secrets
of property development
it is the most amazing book i've ever
written if i do say so myself i think
i've done like six books now
and this one reveals all of the secrets
not just small deals but
big deals and the crash course has now
sold out but
i would like to gift you with a free
copy of the book the secrets of property
development you can get it on amazon
however little disclaimer
it expires tonight so there's just a few
hours and then the book is going to
expire on amazon
and then you're going to have to pay the
full price right now you can get it for
free as a kindle download
doesn't matter if you haven't got a
kindle you can get it on any device
so go down to amazon i'll leave a link
in the description
get the copy of the book it could
potentially change your life it's going
to open your mind up to the kind of
deals that i'm doing now
development deals title splitting
acquiring land building houses from
scratch
read it and then get your eyes peeled
because i'm thinking
soon we'll probably put on some more
dates for some more free training
and i'd love to see you there so get the
book watch this space
be inspired have a great week great
weekend and i will see you
soon